welcome back to 8701
so in this short video we'll talk about
effects
of normalization and higher order qed
diagrams
and we have already seen that when we
perform the integration
of a matrix element over q
that there's infinities and those
infinities can be
getting around with by introducing a
cut-off scale
and then only introducing or only
integrating up to this cut off scale
and as an effect we normalize
or redefine masses and couplings
involved
so the first of such an effect or effect
of higher order
is the so-called vacuum polarization so
you have
higher order contribution which you know
look like this an additional loop
which you can think about in the photon
is thorough energetic that it can
polarize the vacuum produce a particle
on the particle pair
and that particle in anti-carbonic
pair then provides kind of a screening
of the charge you want to probe
so imagine this particle here emits a
photon and wants to probe
the charge electric charge of this
particle
the fact that there is this vacuum
polarization going on screens the charge
you actually want to go
so effectively you see a charge which is
either reduced or increased depending on
the effect
on the sort of effect um for the fine
structure content
constant remember alpha is one over 137
alpha at zero um we measure that
the value of alpha slightly increases
as we go to higher and higher energies
and so this has been measured in many
places experimentally confirmed
for example at lab where at the mass of
the w
or the scale of w mass the value of
alpha has been measured to 1 over 128
and you can do this analytically you can
calculate what the scale of the effect
is
and plot this so you see here the
running of alpha qed
as a function of the energy scale and
you see this increase here
there's another interesting point as you
open up
masses uh new particles of biomass and
squawk and undeclared pairs
you find this kind of stepping approach
here
the new particles for example the mirror
and antimony or quarks
and anticlocks are allowed to use a
stepping function
all right so this is first the first
effect vacuum polarization
a second effect is very interesting
probably one of the
most famous higher order processes in qe
and it has to do with the anomalous
magnetic moment
the magnetic moment is defined as the
factor g
of times e over 2m times s spin of the
particle
diagrams of this form here modify the
vertex
so instead of having a vertex like this
you have higher orders which modify the
voltage this
leads them to
a modified magnetic moment of the
fermion involved in this case of an
electron but you can also define this
formula or a tower any other term
so this was shown by schwinger already
in 1948
and then experimentally confirmed many
times after this g minus
v factor which is two leading order is
modified
to two plus pi over alpha
and next to leading order we can
calculate this to many orders
um and with a
mind-blowing precision so the position
is better than 10 to the minus 12 right
now i think it's 1.7
times minus 13 at this stage and
experiments have tried to measure this
to find new effects
imagine you can have new particles which
make modifications to the magnetic
moment here
and you would have sensitivity by making
experimental measurements
so the electrons and also the mu and g
minus two have
measured with this very high precision
no new physics have been observed but
some
uh differences um some differences are
small
differences have caused quite some
excitement about further improvements in
g minus two measurement specifically for
the neuron so they're ongoing